joining me now for reaction is mike
pompeo former secretary of state and fox
news contributor so why does the left
act as if like conservatives are a
bigger threat to america than the ccp
because in fact we we often are it has
been conservatives that understand uh
the risks from communism and what it
means to us here in the united states
the american left has apologized they
they think america is in decline they
they think that she and
our nation are the same they don't see
the difference they are moral
relativists and then you talked about
this a bit ago it's about money and the
left has got deep ties into the chinese
communist party and their businesses
america's biggest financial institutions
have deep ties into china and they don't
want to walk away from that and so
they'll uh they'll punish americans but
they're not going to do a darn thing
when china behaves in ways that are
deeply inconsistent with america's best
interests
so money and power we established that
now let's talk about the military
superiority issue
which is raised in this new security
pact with the solomon islands i bet most
people you know they kind of know where
the solomon islands are but for most
folks
it doesn't really you know cut through
this this the conversation why is this
so important this particular issue this
of this deal they signed uh this week mr
secretary
laura the chinese have been trying to
expand their footprint in the pacific in
particular in the south pacific for an
awfully long time they began by building
out a set of islands called the spratlys
they put military bases on there after
they promised president obama they
wouldn't and when they did he did
literally nothing
the solomon islands and other islands in
the pacific are places where they can
park
missile systems
naval bases uh naval other naval
capabilities that they can use to
foreclose trade all of the important
trade that moves through all of the
south pacific into the eastern pacific
into places that matter an awful lot to
the united states of america it's why
china is so focused on it it's why in
the trump administration we work so
diligently to try and build out
alliances with those countries the bite
administration has allowed china to walk
all over them throughout the entire
pacific
and lloyd austin had this much awaited
phone call
uh this week with some chinese defense
officials
from the readout it doesn't look like we
got anything out of this call i mean i
mean you have to like read between the
lines but it seems like all we do is get
hectored by china and they're just
moving a pace on everything they want to
do and they don't really care what we
say
well i don't think they they respect or
fear the united states under the
leadership of president biden and the
team
we you the call reminded me of the first
meeting between
uh jake sullivan and secretary blinken
and the chinese that happened in
anchorage where they just they talked
about blm and how we terrorize black
people here in the states and the
american response was to
kind of nod our heads and say well we're
not really that bad
it's hard to imagine why this was the
first call between the chinese and the
secretary of defense after what almost
16 months
and it doesn't look like we actually
defended the things that matter most to
the united states of america our
secretary of defense should have done
that i hope that he did i hope the
readout was incomplete and he was
actually strong and demonstrated
american resolve but as we've seen in
ukraine as we've seen
with chairman kim now firing missiles
out of north korea at a rapid pace over
longer distances this administration
hasn't shown the same resolve in the
same capacity to deter aggression yeah
that we did for four years
no no it is i mean you're not you're too
you're very diplomatic they don't fear
them
they're walking all over them they
didn't even return austin's call for i
think almost a year
i mean what is that all about that that
tells you everything you need to know
and by the way
we're looking for any kind of consistent
uh you know china policy from the
administration but they have no
consistent policy whatsoever
uh and it looks like you know from what
lincoln said last year to what kur john
kirby uh is saying this year the
spokesman over there at the uh
pentagon uh it's not getting any clearer
watch this
i want to be very clear about something
and this is important
our purpose is not
to contain china to hold it back to keep
it down i think we've long been
concerned about china's growing
influence around the world the chinese
continue to try to bully and intimidate
their way
into pursuing their own selfish national
security interests at the expense of
of populations all around the world
mr secretary which is it we're not
trying to contain china and now but
we're very worried about china's
expansion like i mean it's just like the
shrug your shoulders foreign policy i
don't know
yeah laura the chinese communist party
presents the single greatest
external risk to the united states of
america from any place in the world we
called it what exactly it was it was an
adversary of the united states of
america this administration kind of
walked that back and said well we kind
of compete with them no we compete with
norway we compete with sweden the
chinese communist party is trying to
take down western democracy here at home
and they're making a lot of progress we
need real resolve real clarity a strong
posture and build-out friends the
indians the south koreans the japanese
the australians these these are all
people that are threatened by the
chinese communist party as well and we
need to lead the effort to make sure
that the chinese communist party doesn't
dominate global trade and
dominate the global economy in the years
and decades ahead we can do it but it
takes american leadership laura
yeah australia and new zealand watching
this very closely in the solomon islands
mr secretary thank you